ذكر الجيش الباكستاني ان سته المدنيين
قتلوا وجرح 17 اخرون اثر اطلاق النار من
جانب قوات حرس الحدود الافغاني وجاء في
بيان العسكري ان الحادث وقع اليوم في بلده
شامان الحدوديه وان حرس الحدود الافغان
استخدموا اثناء استهدافهم للمدنيين
مدافعون كما ذكر البيان ان قوات الجيش
الباكستاني ردت على مصادر اطلاق النار
بالمثل وانها تجنبت اهداف مدنيه داخل
افغانستان
معنا من اسباب مراسل الجزيره عبد الرحمن
مطر ومن كابو المراسل الجزيره حميد الله
محمد وابدا معك عبد الرحمن عن الروايه
الباكستانيه لما جرى
طبعا الروايه الباكستانيه عبد القادر
تتحدث عن بدء القوات الافغانيه وتحديدا
حرس الحدود الافغان باستهداف المدنيين في
بلده شمن هذه البلده الحدوديه مع
افغانستان والتي يقتنها عاده مدنيون من
التجار من الباعه من الذين يعملون في
المعبر الحدود الرابط بين البلدين والذي
ايضا يحمل نفس الاسم مع بر-من وهؤلاء
الذين تم استهدافهم لم يتحدث البيان
العسكري الباكستاني عن السبب وراء بدء
استهداف قوه حرس الحدود الافغانيه لهؤلاء
المدنيين الجيش الباكستاني قال بان قوه
حرس الحدود الافغانيه استهدف استهدفت
هؤلاء المدنيين بقذائف من مدافع الهاون ما
تسبب في مقتل سته منهم اصابه 17 اخرها
بجراح متفاوت في الخطوره طبعا ايضا الجيش
الباكستاني في بيانه العسكري تحدث بوضوح
وصراحه عن انه ما بي الرد على مصادر
اطلاقا النيران الافغانيه بالمثل وانه
تعمد تجنب الاهداف المدنيه داخل العمق
الافغاني ما يعني بان الجيش الباكستاني
كان يستهدف فقط قوه حرس الحدود الافغانيه
في رده على مصادر اطلاق النار وان الهدف
من ذلك كان هو اسكات همم مصادر اطلاق
النار الافغانيه وليست تسبب باضرار للجانب
الافغاني لكن بالتاكيد هناك الكثير من
التازن في المنطقه الازمه وان ايضا البيان
العسكري تحدث عن انه قد تم التواصل مع
الجانب الحكومي في العاصمه الافغانيه
كابول بشكل مباشر بسبب هذا التطور الخطير
الذي وقع اليوم في المنطقه الحدوديه وبسبب
تلك الضحايا من المدنيين من سكان المنطقه
الحدوديه بالتاكيد سيكون هناك ربما العديد
او الكثير من التبعات لتلك الحادثه ربما
تقدم باكستان خلال الفتره المقبله على
اتخاذ مزيد من الخط وتربى بمزيد من
الاتصالات مع الجانب الافغاني في محاوله
للتعرف على الاسباب التي دفعت قوه حرس
الحدود الافغانيه للبدء باطلاق النار
واستهداف المدنيين داخل الجانب الباكستاني
والدوافع وراء ذلك وما الذي تم تحقيقه
بسبب ترك النيران الافغانيه عبد الله هل
من بيان رسمي في كابول عن ما حدث في شمن
نعم هنا الحكومه الافغانيه تتحدث بان قوه
من القوات الافغانيه ارادت البناء نقطه
الحراسه همم قرب الحدود مما ادت الى
اشتباكات بينها وبين القوات الباكستانيه
التي سارعت الى
القوات الافغانيها الى بناء هذه النقطه
بسبب هناك يعني مشكله تاريخيه بين بلدين
وهي الحدود بحيث الحكومه الافغانيه لا
تعترف بهذه الحدود انك حدود يعني معترف
بها دوليا والجانب الباكستاني ان يراها
حدود دوليه هذه من ناحيه اثناء الاشتباكات
ايضا سكته هناك قتيلين من القوات
الافغانيه واصابه خمسه اخرون ايضا هناك
همم سقط او اصيب اكثر من 20 جريحا معظمهم
من المدنيين حسب الروايه الحكوميه في
ولايه قندهار وايضا الاشتباكات ادت الى
اغلاق معبر سبيل وهذا من اهم المعابر بين
افغانستان وباكستان حيث
يستفيد من هذا المعبر اكثر سكان خمسه
ولايات جنوبيه وايضا هناك مصادر في وزاره
الدفاع الافغانيه تتحدث بان توجهوا قوى
جديده او من قوات اضافيه الى مناطق النزاع
بين البلدين والان الاشتباكات توقفت هناك
يعني همم الوضع متازم جدا في الحدود بين
البلدين وغدا همم
بسادر تتحدث في ولايه
الحكومه الباكستانيه تستمر في اغلاق
المعبر الرئيس بين البلدين ام لا وهناك
ايضا ان همم القوه عسكريه جديده من ولايه
قنديل توجهت الى معبرتك حميد الله محمد
شاهين كابور وعبد الرحمن مطر من اسلام ابا
شكرا جزيلا لكما